when it comes to the sip the big bad
villains of a Star Wars universe there's
more than one way to skin a Jedi some
sit were strong in the force
while others wilted sinister magic or a
huge political influence so who comes
out on top when you add it all up here
are the most powerful Sith ever freedon
Nadd freedon Nadd was a Jedi in the days
of the Old Republic with force talents
far beyond any of his peers while
training he became jealous of his jedi
masters power and authority so in true
Sith fashion he killed him and renounced
his affiliation with the Jedi man what a
baby Ned was trained in the ways of the
dark side by Naga Sadow a Sith Lord
living in exile after his death Friedan
nads ghost continued to manipulate
events from beyond the grave marker rag
nose marker rag nose was a Sith Lord who
grew tired of the city's unwillingness
to expand the on their homeworld of
Corrigan his reign was ruthless and
brutal but most of the time he achieved
victory without raising a finger a
master of manipulation Ragno said his
adversaries against one another using
their mutually assured destruction to
clear an easy path for the Sith and his
story didn't end with his death either
as a force ghost he pitted Sith Lords
against each other for the honor of
becoming the official Dark Lord
Oh
Darth Bane Darth Bane is the Star Wars
Expanded Universe is version of a
founding father when it comes to the
dark side of the force
as the last surviving member of the Sith
Brotherhood of Darkness Bane started a
new Sith order and decided to pass his
knowledge onto a single apprentice
establishing the rule of two that the
Sith Lords have followed ever since
Vader as Anakin Skywalker the man who
had become Darth Vader was expected to
become the most powerful force user of
all time as he had the highest medic
Lorien count ever recorded
I'm wondering what are midi-chlorians
let's not get into that but anyway after
massacring the students of the Jedi
Academy Anakin was severely wounded by
his master obi-wan Kenobi and as the
cyborg Vader he lost some of his
connection to the force still he had
perhaps the most impressive power of all
terrifying generations of moviegoers I
find your lack of faith disturbing darth
nihilus the dark side of the force can
be seen as a metaphor for addiction
darth nihilus offers a perfect example
after he was caught in the detonation of
the super weapon known as the mass
shadow generator which destroyed the
planet malgor five
Nyla's his body was wrecked he was left
with an insatiable craving for force
energy essentially turning him into a
force and vampire
yikes resonate like so many others SIF
revin also started as a Jedi he turned
to the dark side after the Jedi Council
refused to protect the lives of outer
rim innocence caught in the Mandalorian
Wars over their objections revin
assembled a large jedi defense team
helping the republic win the war but
leading him down the dark path to
corruption he eventually embraced the
light side again and helped defeat the
Sith I've known both sides of the force
light and dark Darth Sidious better
known to most fans as Emperor Palpatine
Darth Sidious rose to power thanks to
ruthless cunning after murdering his
master dark Plagueis the Emperor hid in
plain sight as the benevolent Galactic
senator from Naboo secretly
orchestrating the Clone Wars which
allowed him to consolidate political
power Darth Sidious corrupted Anakin
Skywalker and virtually wiped the Jedi
out of existence turning the table after
thousands of years of Jedi dominance
over the Sith I'm afraid the deflector
shield will be quite operational when
your friends
Darth Plagueis Darth Plagueis wasn't the
most skilled force user nor was he a
military leader or particularly good
with a lightsaber
instead Plagueis was a scholar and a
scientist who focused his scholarly
efforts on a single pursuit how to
manipulate the force and midi-chlorians
in a way that would allow him to live
forever and possibly even bring the dead
back to life Darth Plagueis was a Dark
Lord of the Sith so powerful and so wise
he could use the Force to influence the
midi-chlorians to create life with
control over life itself Plagueis feared
only one thing losing his power which he
did when his apprentice Darth Sidious
killed him in his sleep
some fans theorized however that
Plagueis has returned in Star Wars The
Force awakens as the evil Sith Lord
Snoke sounds like bad news for Rey ring
[Music]
Darth Bishop the original Emperor Darth
bishop tricked the other Sith Lords into
helping him perform a ritual that
allowed him to absorb the life force of
every other living being on his home
planet the ritual granted Bishop
immortality and immense power which he
used have found a galaxy spanning Sith
Empire ruling it with an iron fist for
1,300 years I have forged this Empire to
surmount all of my previous works to
span eternity
yeah Palpatine had his moments for a few
decades but when it comes to sitt
Emperor's there's really no contest he
can't be to do with 1,300 years under
his belt thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos that the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know which
Sith Lord you think is the most powerful
ever